a to 192 david p is and has been the
voicemail number for the show
for a long time and today is the last
voicemail of 2017 because we don't do
voicemail on the friday show right and
it is from the Eggman and he is not
pleased with Dilbert creator scott adams
take a listen
dave i want to say just after half of
your interview with the Dilbert dude
that it's a nice nuanced way to look at
politics and the guy looks at all angles
and i appreciate his honesty and looking
at both sides but dave i just deduced
he's simply a rich ass that's it
he wants to sound nice by saying oh
bernie was right about college and
picking infrastructure and helping
Brooke but the guy's a rich ass only if
he's a trickle-down economics douchebag
am I the only one that thinks that why
are you being so nice to him sell him
listen I don't disagree with the eggman
that a lot of what Scott Adams said I
believe is factually wrong I think that
because he is such a wealthy guy I don't
know how much he's worth but it's got to
be close to a hundred million dollars on
off of Dilbert related stuff I actually
think that he doesn't need to hide his
real feelings I think he was being
genuine I just think he's misinformed
about some issues but what better thing
than wrapping up voicemail for 2017 with
another critical hyperbolic voicemail
from the Eggman and what a better way to
end the year with then the interview of
Scott Adams I think too and it sounds
like the Eggman hadn't yet seen the
second part of that interview right
which was I would argue is even better
I believe that part two of the interview
is even better that's right and in
January we will have an explanation
people have been calling in saying could
you give us the origin story of the
Eggman why is he called the Eggman and
who is this guy and why does he call in
and stock days he's been on the show now
he has be and I did it specifically
because we're ending the year on that
but we do have a show tomorrow but
there's no voicemail on it and then in
January of 2018 we will be giving the
Eggman origin story and I think people
will find it pretty compelling great
bonus show today second to last bonus
show of the year sign up we'll talk to
you tomorrow and then in 2018